just so now war for the Planet of the
Apes is the finger we should talk about
some spoilers in war if the planet of
the edge and that is the spoiler warning
for people who have not seen war for the
Planet of the Apes if you haven't seen
it you probably check out my spoiler
free review if you have seen it or don't
care about spoilers welcome point is
let's get into it this movie starts out
it's actually started out really cool
but it was talking about like a virus
wiped out a lot of humanity and made
Apes Mart and it was like then Koba dict
out and started a war with human beings
da and it shows humans really going
after the Apes because they're like oh
whoa clearly they're bad right there
clearly hostile very smart they need to
be wiped out or we are going to be wiped
out though we know that's not the case
it's how they see it and if you really
look at it they have no reason to see it
any other way
thanks Koba but they do see as they
showed in the trailer there are some
Apes that are with the humans because
they're ultimately Koba supporters I
don't know how you can be a Koba
supporter Koba who clearly hated human
beings and then work for human beings I
suppose it's a case of well Caesar and
his Apes killed Koba so the enemy of my
enemy but the point is Caesar's son has
found this great wonderful valley he's
found the Great Valley from land before
time and all the Apes want to go there
but then Woody Harrelson and his crew
invade the camp and Woody Harrelson
kills Caesar's wife and son granted
Caesar does have another son named
Cornelius throwback to the original
Planet of the Apes right there can't be
the same one though right he just can't
be maybe he is but I had to do a
double-take on that I was like it is son
just killed our camera and that's one of
the bummers in this movie is that his
son had such an arc in the last movie in
this one it's like alright here we go
Boba Fett wash and now once again
ultimately like wash from Firefly it
seemed to Brooke but it is used to get
someone into a mindset so now Caesars
like I'm gonna find the [ __ ] who
killed my wife and kid it doesn't matter
I'm consumed with rage and I'm going to
kill him yeah all you other apes go to
the Great Valley I'm gonna kill the
[ __ ] and he goes on a hunt for this
guy and that's where he runs across bad
ape and the little girl little girl is
important because she can't talk you're
like why can't she talk I mean there are
these guys who were dead in the snow
because Woody Harrelson's guys killed
him it's like why can't they talk why
are people not being able to talk why
are the ones who can't talk it and kill
what do you Harrelson Phil's them and
later on but ultimately the big thing is
a virus that made Apes Mart and killed
people has mutated to now affect the
people who lived through it the first
time and now it's ultimately making
people dump they're losing the ability
to talk so just ultimately becoming like
pet
and you start seeing how we get to that
place that the original Planet of the
Apes was in Woody Harrelson's freaked
out he's like I don't want that to
happen to me or my people or we're gonna
kill those people let's kill all the
mutes so when Caesar finally runs across
Woody Harrelson's plays his entire
colony of apes all his friends the ones
he calls family they're all chained up
they're all in cells they're all really
in an internment camp being put to slave
labor because woody harrelson needs to
build a big wall to keep out the humans
who want to wipe him out because he
wants to wipe out the people who are
infected with this virus and they can't
talk ultimately to Woody Harrelson he's
like the human race is on the brink of
destruction because of the virus apes
are already smart as hell they're
stronger than us if we lose our
intellect we are clearly losing the
planet so this is really big hurdle for
the human race Woody Harrelson is just
scrambling to stay above water all the
while Caesar is on a manhunt for this
guidance it is even address in the
movies like Caesar you've become like
Koba you're so consumed with hate and
rage you're blinded and you just want to
hurt the ones who hurt you and that's
where you see some tension between
Caesar and his Apes when he gets
captured he gets thrown into the cells
all the apes are like you left us dude
and now we're here I don't think with
Caesar there they would have gotten out
of that situation they'd all end up
there anyway but it really is an easy
thing to point blame you like this is
your fault and this sucks to see Caesar
in that situation it sucks to see Caesar
on this path from most of the movie but
it sucks it's not to say the movie
starred in the movies great it's a
powerful thing to see such a character
in such a vulnerable state such a human
state he doesn't walk on water
it's like the dark knight taught us even
the best of us can be broken with one
bad day this is yet another movie that
proves the Joker's point really and
interestingly enough I do get for the
first time in a very long time ooh v's
have that whose slave labor it's like
why don't you just kill them all they're
your enemy why don't you kill him this
movie does address the fact he's like
he's trying to build this big wall this
big fortress to keep people out with an
army of a PA you get that wall built in
no time that has always been my problem
with the great Terminator movies called
terminators 1 & 2 the story is the
machines rose and then put people into
slave camps live on earth where they do
what work did they need people to do
that they couldn't do themselves like
yeah the machines could enslave people
or the machines can make stronger more
productive labor in the form of machines
maybe that's with intelligence comes
laziness but in this scenario of the
slave labor thing totally makes sense
and Caesar gets put through the wringer
dude I mean it is winter outside it's
all snowy and cold that what Abe's like
oh here's a drink
water splash all over like half
unfreezing dick you're like oh man
Caesars in the lowest place of his life
he's lost his family his colony hates
him and he's ultimately being tortured
still no war yeah why it's called war
for the Planet of the Apes no idea now
the Lord does happen or at least battle
that the battle happened which one of
the complaints have heard about this
movies if the guards are idiots which is
a transgression that a lot of movies do
because they need guards to be idiots Oh
like how are people ever going to get
out of cells if guards are smarter so in
this one guards yes they are idiots once
again but in this particular situation I
feel like the guards are justified in
being idiots after the matter is so
virus didn't discriminate it wasn't like
everybody but military personnel and
guards gets wiped out and apes get
schmuck no it was just like randomly
people a lot of people on earth died so
these guards are not really guards
denied even military personnel odds are
there were plumbers they were janitors
some of them might have been accountants
who knows and they were told by someone
probably Woody Harrelson's like you need
to sign up with us because if you don't
the human race will be extinct and we
will be a planet of apes
so these shitty nobodies with no skills
whatsoever like alright I guess I'm a
gardener which is why I give this movie
kind of a pass of the fact that the
guards are stupid when the fight goes
down it really is human versus human the
Apes are just trying to get the [ __ ] out
of Dodge but even Cesar's like I can't
go I still need to kill that guy I know
I'm like Koba and I'm flawed because of
it but the guy literally took my family
from me I gotta kill him and he goes up
there to kill him and thing is Woody
Harrelson picked up the doll the little
girl was fidgeting with now Woody
Harrelson is bleeding from his nose and
he can't talk and he's drunk and you're
like oh [ __ ] ain't worse than death
gotta love that poetry he's even taking
the gun to his head he acts like a
zombie that's when Cesar puts down arms
he's like yeah screw this noise the
colonel Woody Harrelson's character just
takes his own gun blows himself away
tragic lives man Cesar's running and he
has his grenades and that dude the pow
the guy he spared at the beginning of
the movie you're like maybe no he ends
up shooting Caesar he's the what he's
the reason he died I know one huge
gorilla just go boom blows the dude up
and you see that one guy slo-mo shot
just takes a gun to the back of that
girl who's headed girls like I don't
care Caesars awesome glad that gorilla
did the turncoat thing then Caesar
throws the grenades at that gas thing it
just blows up you saw in the trailer
because trailers hey so what are you
screw gets wiped out big army strolls up
and then they see Caesar and they look
like they're gonna raise their guns and
a big a blemish comes down and wipes
them out that's the end of Apes well not
yet that Caesar has his last words with
Maurice Maurice starts crying Caesars
been shot and Caesars slowly slowly dies
this is the end of Caesars story Caesars
story is a trilogy it's a very tragic
trilogy when you look at it and who
knows where it's gonna go from there
this is why after this like do they need
more Apes movies no we know where it
ends up however there is undeniably more
story to tell geographically speaking
where it ends up is not where it is
we're pretty close to San Francisco in
these Apes movies the original Planet of
the Apes a little farther how do they
get across the continent don't know I'm
sure there's a travel story in there
somewhere makes me wonder if they are
going to tie in the Charlton Heston's
story or are they going to retell the
Charlton Heston Jeff we saw some Easter
eggs and Rise of the Planet of the Apes
that alluded to the Charlton Heston
story it doesn't mean they necessarily
have to show it or tell it you can have
it just tie in to the Charlton Heston
story although there were Apes movies
that came after that that they have now
rewritten - history - it doesn't all tie
together so it would imply that they do
have to retell it in this universe
meanwhile x-men's like Chaucer's dude it
doesn't matter and guys I'm so glad apes
is a solid trilogy like I said all the
rest of the movies that can suck but
Caesars story is it great trilogy it's a
great drama set and I just hope people
go in here knowing it's not war for the
Planet of the Apes I have to go in there
knowing it's internment camp of the
Planet of the Apes guys so war for the
Planet of the Apes have you seen it what
did you think about it or do you want to
see more Apes movies after this or do
you think now this should stop here
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]